regardez la région de montréal après
cette soirée électorale du rouge est
apparu un peu partout beaucoup beaucoup
sur l'île les libéraux en fait qui ont
repris les endroits traditionnellement
qui votait libéraux qui libéral françois
cormier des résultats vraiments qui font
plaisir aussi à denis coderre qui a
presque fait campagne pour les libéraux
vers la fin où et surtout vers la fin
avec son désaccord sur le déversement
avec le gouvernement conservateur
patrice notez donc qu'il y a maintenant
un bloquiste quatre néo démocrates et 13
libéraux sur l'île de montréal ça
faisait dix ans qu'il n'y avait pas de
député en faisant partie du parti
politique au pouvoir puisque les
conservateurs n'avaient jamais réussi à
faire élire deux députés sur l'île de
montréal
évidemment il était question avec denis
coderre qui réagissait aujourd'hui il ya
des questions de différentes aussi le
plus pressant le fameux des versements
de 8 milliards de litres d'eaux usées
dans le fleuve saint laurent monsieur
trudeau nommant son gouvernement le 4
novembre
ça ne change rien pour l'instant pour
monsieur coderre parce que le
gouvernement au pouvoir restent les
conservateurs en attendant le 4 novembre
cependant il pense qu'on aura peut-être
de moins de pression chez environnement
canada qu'on pourra aller plus vite dans
ce dossier
on peut écouter le maire de morieux
peut-être plus jamais où va se sentir
moins pris parce que la menace peut
faire comme demain parce que moi notant
que je concerné sur le certificat est ce
que vous avez jusqu'au de l'avant par
personne vous pouvez procéder alors si
vous avez un panel qui est capable de
travailler rapidement un produit de
marque lay's sur la tête le j'imagine ce
qui est important france y ont aussi
c'est qu'il y aura des ministres s'est
assuré de montréal parce qu'on n'a pas
vue depuis un certain temps les
ministres responsables de montréal
étaient souvent un élu ou est à l'autre
bout du élus à l'autre bout
du coup avec ça pour un maire c'est un
portable déblocage qu'on attend du côté
de postes canada et et dupont oui il ne
fait aucun doute dans l'esprit de denis
coderre que postes canada devra reculer
quant à sa décision de ne plus livrer le
courrier à domicile donc il espère voir
disparaître les boîtes postales qui ont
été installés sur l'île de montréal pour
le maire également il n'y aura pas de
péage sur le pont c'est assez évident
même son de cloche sur le pont champlain
même son de cloche du côté du
gouvernement du québec on écoute la
ministre des transports avait repris un
jour entendu clairement à part des
libéraux qu'il n'y aurait pas de péage
sur le pont champlain et c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour l'ensemble des
montréalais mais aussi de tous les gens
des régions métropolitaines
moi je pense que c'était certaines
problématiques inquiétantes j'en avais
parlé beaucoup je m'étais exprimé sur le
sujet mais j'avais dit qu'il fallait
avoir aussi un peu de patience on avait
du temps devant nous et le teint a été a
été une bonne décision
un mot pour vous dire que le maire de
laval a également réagi quatre comtés
qui ont viré au rouge il espère un
ministre de laval à la chambre des
communes le maire colère aussi même le
maire labeaume alors que plusieurs
maires finalement travers le pays qui
espèrent des ministres qui viendront de
leurs leurs municipalités de la région
métropolitaine qui c'est françois je
sais que j'ai tient dans sa
circonscription au lierre qui sait mais
annie joly qui voulait être derrière
vous à l'hôtel de ville pourrait se
retrouver au conseil des ministres on
verra voilà ça lui